On a point of order during QP,
the leader of the official opposition yelled across the way here
in respect of the leader of the federal NDP,
and I quote, your leader can't even get back into his home country.
There is no room in this chamber for xenophobic,
racist,
offensive comments towards anyone.
Jugmeet Singh, for the information of the Official Opposition,
was born in Canada. He is a Canadian citizen
and he is a kind and compassionate and caring
and brilliant and respectful Canadian citizen.
I cannot just stand by while the leader of the official opposition
just spouts off disgusting rhetoric
to the leader of the federal NDP.
I would ask that the leader of the official opposition
stand in his place and apologize
not only to everyone in this chamber
but to Jughead Singh himself.